hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game between mikhail tal and
nonagaprindashvili and uh i'm guessing
you guys already know why i'm showing
this game but i'm also showing it for a
lot of different reasons and i want to
just mention why is that uh we you've
seen in the news that uh gabriel dash
really has sued netflix uh for
uh well um
basically uh tarnishing her legacy so so
to say uh because if you've seen the
queen's gambit and you're familiar with
the character of elizabeth harmon or
beth harmon
then you know that uh well uh she's sort
of in this fictional world where there
are all of the other chess players that
are actually uh present in that day and
age except for bobby fischer for some
reason uh but uh yeah nonagapi
industrially also appears in the in one
of the episodes of the queen's gambit
it's in the last episode and when the
commentator is talking about um uh well
a lot of different things elizabeth
harmon just arrived in russia uh for a
brief moment uh he mentions and
these are the exact words from the
netflix series uh the only end he's
referring to elizabeth harmon the only
unusual thing about her really is her
sex and even that's not unique in russia
he says there's none agaprindashvili but
she's the female world champion and she
has never faced men and that could not
be further from the truth and
she sued netflix for the sum of i
believe
five million dollars or even more than
five million dollars uh as uh
well just uh just to give you an example
she won her uh grand master title uh by
uh defeating some very very strong
players for example these are the
standings of the lone pine tournament
where she after which she got her uh
grand master title and you can see that
she won fourth place in the tournament
where a lot of very strong grand master
have played some of them you know some
of them you don't but okay there are
there are a lot of them a lot of players
in this tournament uh but the just some
of them uh that we have mentioned on
this channel throughout uh the years uh
for example there's yasir serevan uh
there's uh samuel ruschevsky there's uh
paul benko there's walter brown there's
uh larry christian and sanders william
lombardi uh and then you can see
nonagaprindashila in fourth place so
this is basically determined that uh
where she got her grandmaster norm and
uh she's the first woman ever to do so
uh so she already was the women's world
champion but she's the first women ever
to receive the actual grandmaster title
because you know uh in chess there are
uh
there are general titles like uh
candidate master affiliate master
international master grand master but
there are also uh women's titles which
are of course the women candidate master
women's video master women's
international master and women's
grandmaster so she is the the absolute
first who got the actual grand master
title and uh that's something that um uh
well of course anyone would wouldn't
take lightly if netflix uh said
something about this and it's uh also
very weird that the netflix tv series
the queen's gambit is based on a walter
tevis book also called the the queen's
gambit but the line in the book is much
much different from the line in the
actual series uh for example in the book
it says there was no naga industrially
not up to the level of this tournament
but a player who had met all these
russian grandmasters many times before
and while i could show you many of her
games that where she achieves great
victories brilliant victories where she
defeats other
grand grandmasters i decided to show you
this one it's against my absolute
favorite chess player of all times
mikhail tal uh and it's a game she loses
but the story of this game will just
show you the the character of
nonagaprendashvili and what uh kind of a
fighter she is uh because as the story
goes uh before this uh tournament uh
i'll basically uh i'll offer her a draw
and we're gonna discuss why after i show
you the game uh that and of course she
declined this and she said that she
wants to fight there's gonna be a real
really big struggle for the first place
and she wants to play an actual game
against misha and while we are going to
uh discuss this a little bit more uh
let's check out the game first and uh
something that also she said it's
translated from georgian she says that
they were trying to do this fictional
character who was blazing the trail for
other women uh when in reality i had
already blazed the trail and inspired
generations it was an insulting
experience
this is my entire life that has been
crossed out as though it is not
important and she's currently 80 years
old and she's still competing and she's
still playing in tournaments of course
against both um
both genders uh but okay let's check out
the game and then we're gonna discuss
this a little bit more so tal has the
white pieces and he opens the uh with e4
this was uh
uh played
in reykjavik and it was played
well a few years after tao already
became world champion he already lost
his title too but finnick but let's
focus on the game now so e4 we have e5
and uh i was
i was thinking about whether to show you
this game or her game against boris
posky and her game against saposki is
even more impressive but like i said
there's a reason i'm showing this one we
have knight to f3 knight to c6 we have
bishop to b5 going for the roy lopez a6
nana goes for the morphys defense bishop
to a4 and now knight to f6 so this is
something that we see pretty much every
day uh we have castles and now bishop to
e7 we have rook to e1 and now b5 pushing
the bishop back all the way to b3
we have d6 and now c3 so now you have
the c2 square available for your bishop
and also
at any moment you can execute the the
central push with the d4 we have castles
by nonna and now h3 we have knights to
a5 going after the bishop preparing c5
and the bishop to c2 and now of course
c5 so this has been played many many
times nothing out of the ordinary here
tall strikes in the center with the d4
and
once again this position has been
reached so many times uh wesley so had
it against magnus cross and anand headed
against the vaseline manchu kasparov
headed against ponomariov uh kasparov
headed against evan chu topalov had it
against ivan chuk so uh there's
there's no player you know who who was
in the top of world chess that did not
play this uh so here uh you might go
some like queen to c7 bishop to b7 or
you could uh
reduce the tension in the center and
then continue development which is what
nona does so c captures on d4 c captures
and queen to c7 putting pressure on the
on the c file the bishop b7 rook to c8
with more pressure on the c file that's
the plan and at some point this knight
is probably coming to c4 so knight b to
d2 does going for the usual knight to f1
and then to e3 or g3 depending on what
black plays bishop to b7 and now knight
to f1 uh we have rook ate the c8 putting
pressure on this bishop here and bishop
to b1 this is fairly common here against
uh
such a setup in rural opus to place your
bishops on b1 and c1 nothing weird is
happening here and now uh you might
consider a move like e cap person d4 or
d5
simply to prevent white from playing
sorry simply to prevent white from
playing d5 but first she goes rook to f8
she wants to put more pressure on this
pawn and you will later be able to play
some like queen to b8 queen to a8 and
then put even more pressure on the e4
pawn and this is what nona is playing
for so knight's the g3 that adds another
defender here and now g6
uh so now the bishop can be shifted to
f8 to g7 we have bishop to g5 now the
dark squares have been weakened do you
want to play queen to d2 and now knight
to c4 and now comes b3 and it is as of
move 18 that this position has never
been reached again so let's see what
happens here uh so you have to move the
knight if you go to a3 which seems like
a reasonably good move for example
bishop to d3 you don't really have all
that many ideas here with the knight if
you go knight to the seat yes it seems
nice it kind of seems like white has to
trade but just rook c1 and you blunder
this knight so of course you're not
gonna do that so instead nona goes back
knight to b6 and now we have bishop to
d3 just continuing development
tal is preparing rook to c1 so knight b
to d7
and now rook to c1 so you as you can see
the tension in the center has still not
been been resolved no captures were made
and the d5 still was not played so the
queen is attacked we have queen back to
d8 uh and now tau trades on c8 rook
captures queen captures and now queen to
d2 uh joining the bishop on the dark
square diagonal
and now we have bishop to f8
so what do you play here uh well you
could play something like d5 but i i i
think the reason tal uh refrain from
playing d5 is that even though
positionally it makes sense uh tal uh
well he he's more in favor of an open
game than a closed game even if it tends
to give him a little bit of an advantage
so he goes back bishop to b1 uh and now
comes uh queen to a8 like we said
putting more pressure on this e for pawn
so here bishop to h6 the pawn is for the
moment sufficiently defended by the
knight rook and bishop uh and here nonna
trace with bishop captures queen
captures and now you don't have to worry
about any knight to g5 ideas the knight
is covering h7 uh so rook the e7 uh
queen is coming to fate and now nona
will also offer a queen trade tal of
course as you know will decline this
he's he was never much of a queen trader
we have rook to c1 tal now puts the rook
on the only open file on the board he
wants to bring the rook to c7 and now
queen to f8 no no offers a queen trade
and tal of course declines queen back to
d2 and now finally we have d5
so this d5 now
comes with a with a pawn sacrifice but
you have to you have to try something
you could also try to just keep the
tension but nona
is a fighter and she wants the position
to open up even against a player like
tal so knight captures an e5 knight
captures on e5 and now d captures an e5
and now the problem is you can't really
go for rook captures on e5 if you play
rook captures on e5 then you allow tal
this very dangerous expansion with uh
f4 attacking the rook and once the rook
moves e5 attacks the knight and now you
don't really have a good option here you
you're gonna have to play knight to e4
if you go knight back for example knight
to d7 then rook to c7 and you're in big
trouble here both the knight uh and the
bishop are attacked so you'd have to
play something like knights to e4 and
then after let's say bishop captures on
e4 pawn captures you're gonna play queen
to d4 and now there's no defending this
pawn so tal would win a pawn here uh
whether it's enough it's hard to say but
it is a pawn and he he he was better on
the clock as um as the story goes so
after d captures on e5 uh no no goes for
this knight captures on e5 idea bishop
captures on e5 uh on e4 and now d
captures an e4 and now queen to f4
guarding the e5 pawn uh and preparing to
capture on e4 we have queen to b8 now
putting pressure on the e5 pawn and the
top plays rook to c5 defending this pawn
and now
again you have to decide how to continue
here do you want to
keep this pawn or do you want to lose
this pawn here nona decides to give up
this pawn uh you could defend it with f5
uh it's uh seems like a very nice pawn
expansion here uh of course so you can't
capture e captures an f6 alpha song
because you blunder the queen here so
tal would have to do something else but
it's um
well the white king is very safe here
and now the black king is kind of wide
open and you don't really have uh all
that much to do with black for example
we're gonna show a line knight to e2 now
we're going to move the queen and bring
the knight into the game for example
queen to d8 now preparing to trade rooks
here but also threatening to win the
knight with uh queen to d1 check so
let's say king h2 and now rook to c7 uh
removing some of white's attackers queen
to c1 defending the rook now let's say
captures captures and king to f7 and we
would get a position like this where
white would definitely get the f4 square
for his knight and then it's uh
completely crazy for example if g5
there's even e6 with check king six and
now uh white black is in a lot of
trouble queen to c3 check king e7 and
now queen to g7 check and this is just
so ugly king to d6 and now let's say
queen captures and b7 you trade bishop
for a knight pawn captures and now let's
say queen captures an a6 check king the
e7 uh and queen captures on b5 you're
gonna capture on e6 and you would get
this position where it's a queen pawn
end game uh tal is up a pawn but black
has this massive pawn structure here
that can be pushed forward i guess so
it's a complete madness here but with uh
nana being low on time of course it's a
lot to calculate but it's uh it's a
possibility of course f5 just defends
the pawn and then you take it from there
she decides to give up this pawn she
plays queen to d8 and now how do you
continue well thal grabs the pawn knight
captures an e4
bishop captures an e for queen captures
and now f6 the pawn cannot capture the
queen is on e4 so queen to c2 now not
allowing nana to capture back because if
you capture back then just rook here and
then you're in a lot of trouble you lose
the queen so after queen to c2 we have
queen to d4
and what do you play here well of course
uh you first deliver the check rook the
c8 check king f7 and now you capture the
pawn on f6 and now this is another
moment where nonna could have
gone for the easy way out she she
already refused a draw before the game
she wanted to play she wanted to fight
but now she refuses another one it would
seem here rook the e1 check and it's
hard to
uh do anything really with white for
example king to h2 queen e5 check you
have to play g3 uh or if you go f4 of
course just queen captures on f4 so g3
and now rook to e2 attacks the queen
threatens rook captures on f2 and now
you don't really have all that much with
white you could just play rook to c7
check rook to see it rook the c7 check
rook to e8 and go for some sort of a
perpetual or you could go for this queen
trade and after captures captures you
would capture on f6 now this is hanging
and this is hanging so king g2 we have
to defend our pawn no no would capture
here tal would capture on h7 and you get
this position where uh tal is up upon
but for example rook a3 one pawn is not
all that much in rook and pawn end games
for example rook to a7 and now b4 and
this is very very hard to uh to play
because at any point if this rook
somehow activates you can just push the
pawn create a pass pawn uh and uh well
or if this rook ever moves from the
defense or or rather the attack of the
a6 pawn you just capture this one so
it's uh
all in all should not be in
all that difficult but nona uh
declines this idea she goes for queen to
a1 check instead king the h2 uh and here
uh tal already saw that nonna was
going low on time and he didn't want to
win on time so he allowed his time
to run out
not really but he he didn't push the
clock and then nona said if he does this
one more time that she will resign the
game right away and then tal of course
had to play so here we have queen
captures on f6 grabbing that pawn and
now rook to c6 by tal attacking the
queen and going after the a6 pawn we
have queen to f4 check g3 and now queen
to f3 uh so now this is the position
that noah had in mind uh i guess going
uh uh instead of that uh drawish line
that we discussed uh because now rook to
e2 again could be deadly but tal finds
rook captures on a6 and that this is not
a problem now the problem with rook to
e2 going for this seems crushing but the
black king is wide open so queen to c7
check and there's no defense king the g8
okay you don't have rook to a8 because
the queen covers the a square uh but you
could easily play queen to c8 to check
and now
you don't really have anything if king
to g7 then you play rook to a7 check and
now it came to h6 there's
queen to see one check there's no
defense against this uh g5 now you go
back rook to a6 check and then after the
king moves you pick up the g5 pawn and
of course it's all over king to f8 rook
to f6 with check you win the black queen
and that's it you don't have anything to
worry about so after queen to see it
check you couldn't really move the king
you would have to block with the queen
but now it's a much different end game
we just trade queens captures captures
play king to g2 now we're up two pawns
and of course this will be easily
winning for tal so after this rook
captures an a6 no not can't go for rook
to e2 he if she plays king to g7 uh the
king will now be able to to hide on h6
and then maybe you will be able to play
rook to e2 but now tao played queen to
be to check and i believe it was in this
position that nonna's clock ran out she
ran out of time and then she she
resigned i do not have this exact same
information maybe she resigned here but
as she was
very much low on time it could also be
that her time ran out but whatever you
decide to do uh white is clearly much
better here for example if you go king
to g8 we can simply play rook to f6 and
there is no more attack for black white
is just up material uh the game is still
not over of course you have to play it
but uh you will no longer have any
pressure on the f2 pawn the queen has to
move you don't have time for rook to e2
uh so there's that and if the king
doesn't allow rook to f6 you could also
play some like king to f7 uh then we
play queen to d2 so it's really not a
problem and now again you can't continue
rook to e2 runs into rook to a7 check
and after
let's say rook back to e7 you just play
queen to d4 you keep an eye on this
and you don't have a worry in the world
of course you're going to trade this you
don't mind going into a queen and
opponent give me rob two pawns uh so of
course he would be winning for tal uh
but yeah after queen to d2 uh nona
resigned or her time ran out i i i do
not have the information i believe her
time ran out but could also be that she
just resigned
but this is the game i wanted to show
you like i said even though i could have
shown you any game where she defeats a
strong grandmaster i decided to show you
this one
as
she she was offered a draw before the
game she was offered a draw during the
game tao tried to allow his time on the
clock to run out she did not allow it
she said okay you do it one more time
i'm going to resign
she wanted to fight tal in his best she
wanted to you know she she didn't go
for any easy ways out and even though
history might remember that um
she you know got a draw against uh
former world champion such as the the
great magician uh she refused of course
and she wanted to fight and
tal also mentions this in his book uh
life and games of mikhail tal and i'm
just going to read a very small part
from the book
so here tal says on this day a telegram
arrived from moscow saying that nona had
been awarded the title of honored master
of sport of the ussr and as a senior
calling
i arranged a small banquet
to which a number of the competitors
were invited the following day i was due
to play nona i didn't think at the
moment i had the right to play for a win
and so i said to the lady champion that
i was not averse to agreeing to a draw
to my surprise nana displayed her
character and said that in view of the
close battle for first place i was
obliged to play only for a win
then i suggested her that she
she should name an opening which she
would like me to play she agreed to this
end naturally without any additional
preparation i said down at the board i
now felt more confident and even had the
right to think of revenge the point was
that a new year lightning tournament had
been held in hastings and in the final
of this nona had scored three out of
three and i only two points i gained my
revenge in reykjavik talking about this
game that we've just seen and in the
course of play i was once more made
aware of the georgian ladies champion
like character already upon down nonna
got into time trouble but when not
wishing to win on time i forgot to press
my clock on a couple of occasions nana
says to me in hissing whisper if you do
that again i'll resign straight away
taken from pages 241 to 242
of the life and games of mikhail tal by
the by the great misha himself
uh so uh once again i could have shown
you any game where she defeats a strong
player but uh really this uh this game
against uh uh
mikhail shows her true character and why
she is definitely a true champion and
you know uh maybe uh
not maybe definitely netflix should have
considered not throwing in that line
because it was not in the original work
of uh
walter tevis uh and uh they really
changed it and uh she got a reply from
netflix and that the producer of the
series uh
said that netflix has only the utmost
respect for ms gabrin dashville
and her illustrious career but we
believe this claim has no merit and will
vigorously defend the case so we'll see
what happens uh with with this lawsuit
and uh what it will bring but uh
definitely it will
a lot of people will learn more about
her and that it wasn't really the case
uh because one thing i noticed when i
started making video videos from the
games of the queen's gambit played by
beth harmon uh of course those games are
all fabrication but the queen's gambit
got so many people in the chest that
were never interested in chess and you
know i i think i made three videos on
the games that you played in that series
uh all of them got over a million views
i think one video got maybe even five
million views i don't know and uh
a lot of people were amazed that uh beth
harmon was not a real character they
were they were they were devastated that
she was not a real character because she
inspired them so much and then when they
started googling about beth harmon they
were like oh she's a fictional character
oh oh damn and of course it's uh it's
sad that uh when you have a real
character who definitely paved the the
way for other women the the first woman
ever to achieve the the actual title of
grandmaster uh is belittled like this
maybe in a you know in a netflix tv
series so i'm not a lawyer of course i
do not know such things but i'm very
much interested in your comments and
will definitely follow up on this uh
after you know this is resolved uh maybe
with a with a a
a game where no not defeats a strong
grandmaster uh but i felt like for this
video this game perfectly illustrates uh
nona's character and why this was well
at least was not cool from the netflix
side
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it i would like to thank
john dugdale ultra fan faceoff antoine
bull
apolog for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions checking up on
whatever else happening in the chess
world and uh you know just uh do doing
what i usually do
uh so yeah thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of the
day